un chalet de neuf plancher de bois très
moderne très vitre et voici yvan le
françois il est promoteur immobilier et
président de développement dérive
il y a trois ans il vend à léon
jolicoeur et à sa conjointe un chalet à
entrelacs qui présente plusieurs vices
de construction
la fosse septique n'était pas au niveau
là ça fait c'est vers la propriété la
moitié du balcon entre aller jusqu'à
l'arrière 15 mars que la porte patio
avec nour avec l'adresse l'ingénieur
embauchée par le couple affirme que le
drain français est dysfonctionnel et le
mur de soutènement est hautement à
risque pour la stabilité du bâtiment
il n'y avait rien de confort me suis
autant le drain français que
l'enrochement qui parle en retour de
sean coût des travaux près de 30000
dollars au québec
un promoteur immobilier doit posséder
une licence de la régie du bâtiment
d'entrepreneur général afin d'offrir la
garantie des maisons neuves obligatoires
or depuis 15 ans yvan lefrançois ne
possède pas il est très connu à la rbq
monsieur le françois si son entreprise
ont été condamnés à deux occasions une
condamnation pour du travail 110 ans en
2018 avec une amende de 34 mille dollars
et en 2019 une autre condamnation avec l
amende de 32 mille dollars
ouah de toute bonne foi est passé
d'acheter de quelqu'un cavaliers 102 sur
la france souhaite un individu qui m'a
la neige est un récidiviste
si on parle pour lui vaut continuer son
manège ceux qui cachent des maisons lui
il voit le françois a refusé de nous
rencontrer et soutient que tous les
travaux ont été faits selon les règles
de l'art
actuellement l'entreprise possède des
permis de construction au lac rouge à
saint didace 4 aux amendes totalisant
plus de soixante mille dollars
elles n'ont toujours pas été payés ici
nenci desjardins radio canada montréal